on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
I am Rosanna Lockwood here on uncensored
tonight you have guinea pregosian led a
failed Mutiny against Putin back in June
tonight Russia's mercenary boss is
believed to be dead as a private jet
explodes just north of Moscow we'll have
the latest on an extraordinary
developing story out of Russia
also tonight more than 2 000 Treasures
worth millions stolen from the British
Museum and our countries like Greece are
saying it shatters the myth that the UK
is the best place for histories in loot
so should we be giving it all back we're
debating that
plus and only fans model Sparks outrage
by advertising host solicit services on
billboards in London and New York are we
normalizing obscenity or just being
prudish the model in the eye of the
storm joins me live
[Music]
this is Piers Morgan uncensored with
Rosanna
good evening welcome to Piers Morgan on
science with me Rosanna Lockwood in the
chair for peers tonight yevgeni
pragosian the feared boss of Russia's
Wagner group this mercenary Army accused
of atrocities in Ukraine and across
central Africa in June you might
remember pregosian sees the world's
attention by launching a failed Mutiny
against President Putin himself and
tonight he is believed to be dead
a private jet flying from Moscow to
Saint Petersburg has crashed north of
Moscow gregorian's name was on the
passenger list according to Russian
authorities and information now videos
do appear to show a plane falling from
the sky
eyewitness reports suggests though
allowed Banks shortly beforehand Wagner
linked social media channels accused
Russian air defenses of shooting down
the plane Putin of course branded
evgenic precaution as treasonous after
that failed coup and then exiled him to
Belarus but pregotian remained the head
of the Wagner group and appeared in a
video in Africa only this week so has
Russia's dictator exacted the ultimate
revenge for a power play that shocked
the world last month or back in June
rather or as is so often the case in
Russia is there more to this story than
meets the eye for more on this I'm
joined by a big panel this evening the
author of freezing order surviving
Vladimir Putin's wrath Bill Browder
joins us once again as well as the
former head of MI6 Sir Richard dear love
and dissident Diplomat borresponderov
who worked for the Russian permanent
mission to the UN at Geneva before
resigning in protest over the invasion
of Ukraine thank you gentlemen Boris
um I'll start with you then how reliable
is information that we've got from the
Russian authorities do you think
well it is very hard to judge whether it
is reliable or not because all
information flows in Russia are strictly
controlled by the government so they
just let it out only what they want to
let out but it seems that according to
all information sources we have now that
it is more likely that precaution is
dead than otherwise
same to be
to be waited in the favor of him being
dead given of course that Peyton has
branded uh him a traitor various times
and anybody who gets branded a traitor
by Putin tends to end up dead uh Sir
Richard dear love when you heard the
information this evening what were your
thoughts on it
well I wasn't particularly surprised by
the news
but on the other hand I think one
approaches
the reports with caution
was prevulsion of the aircraft did it
crash was it shut down what were the
weather conditions I mean there are so
many questions to which we don't know
the answer I've seen video clips uh on
the internet it looks as though it
crashed in fine weather and you know if
that really is the plane coming down it
almost looks as it was shot down
um no but there are many questions I
mean we have to speculate but
uh the fact that precaution might be
dead as far as I'm concerned that's
unsurprising news it was a matter of
time
unsurprising yes and Bill uh coming to
you unsurprising to many people of
course you know we had the the quips and
the gaffs almost over the last two
months since the Mutiny that there would
be an open window that uh pagodian would
find his way out of uh and the rest of
it but in terms of uh appropriating any
kind of value to what has happened this
evening you get people saying well this
is It's brilliant news of course he was
a mercenary boss if indeed he is dead
um but it's also a sign that Putin is
strengthened somewhat could be read like
that
absolutely I mean the way I look at this
whole thing is that the fact that
pagosian was running around for two
months
um sort of unkilled you know that he was
still alive uh having meetings being in
Moscow being in St Peter's being in
Africa every day that he was alive it
was a another day of humiliation for
Putin
um Putin is a strong man he's a dictator
uh the way he stayed in power for the
last 22 years has been by scaring
everybody by by sending the message that
if you are disloyal and disrespect him
um you will end up in jail or dead and
and the fact that um uh pagosian wasn't
dead
um it was a humiliation for Putin and
sort of opened the door for for other
people to have a go at Putin and so
um this is a for Putin this is a very
good day because he's effectively
re-established his authority he's he's
put um put himself back as the boss of
the prison yard and um uh well pregosian
is an odious murdering character I don't
think that we should in any way be
celebrating this because we this only
strengthens Putin yeah indeed it's it's
sort of a strange mixed celebration for
some if they do indeed want to celebrate
of course the death of a mercenary boss
but as you've laid out there a lot more
complexities to this and you know the
older Dodge that we were going to see
Putin flailing with after the coup has
not been proven true at all uh let's
then talk then Boris about
the way this may have happened if we are
to believe uh the reports are true that
progression was on board eight bodies
have been uh supposedly recovered from
the crash site according to Russian
authorities once again and we are unable
to independently verify that beyond the
information that we've got
if that is the case what do you make of
the fact that it was a private jet do
you think that was an error a weakness
of precautions to choose to travel like
that around through Russia
uh well I've noticed that Ferguson has
so far traveled by things private jets
many times since he's muting so for
these two months so I think it was a
very comfortable way of traveling for
him perhaps he didn't suspect anything
perhaps if he is really dead by now he
was very naive and not that intellectual
kind of person so he believed to believe
the insurance is given by president
lukashenko of Belarus or President Putin
himself and so he believed that he was
safe
insecure and then that the Wolves would
keep the words and not nothing will
threaten him his life his people and and
all so well evidently it's not the case
but it it it says to all of us again
that people in Russian Elite on top of
Russia are not that clever are not that
intelligent they are mostly behave and
think like common criminals without
thinking through the consequences of the
actions
so we shouldn't be afraid of them be
afraid of their strategies afraid of
their mind anything we should deal with
them uh for what they are criminals
there's some scam reassurance we had
there um gentlemen Sir Richard Dillard I
will come back to you shortly I'm very
interested to know how the security
services would behave in a situation
this but I want to introduce the
conversation someone else as well John
Sweeney who has been reporting from
Ukraine I believe for 500 and something
plus days now John you're able to
correct me on the exact figure but how
do you think this information will be
received by ukrainians today
the moment it happened it happened I
ordered a precaution Burger
and
said EB
[Music]
um
so how
there are people saying so
on a plane to Adina
unfortunately John we're struggling to
hear you we've got some connection
issues we'll come back in a moment so
we'd like to cross back over to Sir
Richard dearlov um and just talk to you
give me a roll former head of MI6 what
the security services
um our intelligence Services here in
Britain might be doing right now in
terms of trying to verify this
information what it means for
um those that are based in Russia as
well in terms of gathering more
information and what that's what this
means for the outcome of Putin's
presidency as well
well obviously there'll be attempts I
mean this is picked up on my part but
there'll be attempts going on as we
speak to verify the story and there are
all sorts of ways and means of doing
that particularly in an aircraft crash
because you've got Air Traffic Control
you've got flight records you've got all
sorts of
other sources half of which are open
sources on which you can draw and try to
find out the background and the detail
but I mean I think there will be a
reluctance to make any sort of statement
or official reaction until the
information is clearly and strongly
verified I mean we used to say when I
worked on issues Russian and I'm talking
about Soviet Russia that it was always
better to take the line that nothing in
Soviet Russia happened by accident and I
think you know in relation to these
events surrounding alleged precaution
killing that you know this
may not be an accident or one should
maybe start from an assumption that it
isn't an accident so I think the same
rules apply to Putin's Russia as applied
to Soviet Russia where the issue of as
it were controlled but I think the other
thing we ought to reflect on is you know
there are nine other people on the
aircraft they are all presumably uh
killed in the crash
um I I mean this is extraordinary season
events and in a way shows the
desperation disarray and problems that
the Russian leadership faces even if one
does see it as a reassertion of Putin's
Authority that idea of nothing happening
by accident in in Russia a bill I know
that will chime very true to some of the
things you've experienced but let's talk
about that a bit more relating to
brigosian and the Mutiny which was
exactly two months ago to this day again
seems a little bit coincidental at the
plane will come down today and again uh
Putin's aggressive reinvasion of Ukraine
happened around the time of an
anniversary as well he is somewhat
coordinated in his moves isn't he
uh he's absolutely coordinated and and
from Putin's perspective
um uh the thing that always uh troubled
me was why did he not um engage in a
purge of all these mutinous uh people
like pagosian and those who sided with
him the day after the the Mutiny and um
and what we also um know about Putin is
that that he you know he never forgives
never forgets and so
um it it seems like he was from that
moment on planning a massive Purge I
think that pagosian is the first I don't
think he's the last I think there are
other people involved in this whole uh
exercise that will also find themselves
uh dead and and um uh Putin had to do
this he he couldn't not do this if he
wanted to stay in power and so
um that this is this is the obvious
result of of a person who is disloyal
and who turned on him and and I I guess
everybody expected it to happen and here
we are in less burgosian somehow uh uh
put his name on the Manifest um he's
dead and and that's that's the you know
that's what Putin needs to show
everybody else and again that is still a
possibility because anything is possible
sometimes when it comes to Russia and
you know we are going by this
information as Boris said to start this
conversation it seems weighted more
likely that precaution is dead as a
result of this but we do have to wait
and see a bit more
um we were just showing pictures there
of uh Vladimir Putin president Russia
from Russian State media at a concert
today these are pictures of him walking
on stage looking very happy and um you
know doing the old I'm very busy uh
nothing to do with what's going on
elsewhere so uh very interesting to see
those
uh Boris coming back to you then on
Bill's point about why there wasn't a
purge of these close
um
you know potentially changeable
characters in the Kremlin forgot your
nickname Putin Chef obviously was very
close to him for many years and then
sort of was allowed to go off on one and
do what he did in Ukraine and have his
mercenary Army why wasn't there a purge
why hasn't this been controlled sooner
in the Kremlin
I believe first it's not
Putin's habit a tradition to make purges
she likes things go down smoothly and
quietly
so um that is why I doubt that there
will be any significant purchase now in
the in the ranks of presidential
Administration or military or whatever
um why they did not do anything like
this sooner
in these two months I believe the the
very the same reason why they didn't
suppress suppress the Rebellion the
Mutiny on this very day
they just were unable to do though
everybody saw that precaution marched
well Wagner group march on Moscow
without any resistance without any
people trying to block the roads or
anything so if pregozian did push
further he may have ended in Moscow and
nobody knows what would happen then so I
believe Putin found himself to be well
in very uncomfortable situation he
didn't have enough resources to stop
pregosium and when pragosan agreed to
withdraw and when they struck a deal
with the help of Mr lukashanka or
without
then Putin was gathering resources he
was waiting for a proper opportune
moment to strike today it is well likely
is the day he chose to strike but Putin
I I would like to reiterate that Putin
is not that all-powerful that he used to
be
and this uh killing of tiboson if it is
by Putin design
does not strengthen him either
he was weakened and diminished by the
Mutiny of the Goshen itself and he is
very weak response to that and now he
may try to kill kugosen or Mr utkim the
right hand of Prego someone else but it
will not change the fact that Witten was
Putin showed weakness during the Mutiny
and it gives a clear signal to anybody
who would like to repeat his precaution
experience yeah they will understand
that they just must push to the end and
that's and then they can manage the
situation it's never moving and worrying
situation in terms of that tumult that
which John Sweeney has managed to rejoin
us with a more stable connection John
just interested to quickly get your
thoughts about how this information
might be received in Ukraine this
evening
well I already know the moment I heard I
ordered a uh begotten Burger
and Rachel in the restaurant I mean said
are you sure he's dead and then he
laughed so everybody here knows just how
evil how barbarous how murderous the
wagnerites have been
um they have committed War Crime After
War Crime After War crime and so there
is this is Ukrainian national flag day
tomorrow is Ukrainian Independence Day
so the mood hearing Kiev is exalted if
it's true that he's dead
um to be honest I would put a fiver on
him being dead
tons of my Ukrainian friends are being
skeptical the the some are saying you
know let's see the DNA evidence some
people are saying he's already in
Argentina wearing a wig but the the
sense here is this is great because
precaution was an evil man there's no
doubt about that whatsoever but also it
weakens Putin the fact that Putin has
had to
um it feels like that he has had this
man killed means that he is a fragile
monster it means that he is murdering
his own people and that for the
ukrainians here in Kiev and across the
whole country it feels like that soon
sooner perhaps than many people in the
west think that comeuppance will come
for the master of the Kremlin himself I
can imagine they are waiting for that
day with baited breath look John Boris
Bill Richard thank you very much for
making time
uncensored next tonight Treasure's worth
millions stolen from the British museum
with countries like Greece saying it
shatters the myth the UK is the best
place for history's loot so should we be
handing it all back we'll be debating
that next
[Music]
thank you
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King Q I
think there's only one for one king
he's mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail about working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
war but it's making me cry again they're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Hugh Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
Scandal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through in that in some way
is an excuse yeah for what appears to be
an abuse of power when they first got
together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth because you're
not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job that resonates with
people Elaine Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I
obviously wish I'd never met him
the conservative party can certainly win
the next election yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they've bent the rules or lied on the
visa application form and therefore got
it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
foreign
[Music]
if we stop producing oil the knock-on
effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know you're probably going to
whoop me off
some of them they're easily lit
you can kiss my American Air
thank you very much very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you that's
the threat that you'd be worried about
so are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
what does a woman make
you weren't asked to give evidence to
the grand jury I'm the only one that has
Battalion materials you don't drink
never taken drugs you're stinking Rich
should we be concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
Prime Minister President Trump Mr
President first lady Stormy Daniels
Jordan Peterson welcome to all these
people protesting just don't get it many
of them don't isn't that slightly
patronizing
when you're going through the treatments
you have some tears God I'm such a softy
I'm not a performing monkey come on
Brian and it's something that really
hurt me because they doubt of my words
a woman is me a woman is somebody whose
breasts hang down to her stomach I
thought the marginalized we're supposed
to have the voice I've been a terrible
liar
you're being a Karen pass Morgan
kiss condoms to kiss caskets we'll get
you coming and we'll get you going I
think it's only room for one king man
now I'm saying
oh
[Music]
a reminder you can vote for Piers Morgan
uncensored in the best TV interview
category at the National Television
Awards you can do this by going online
having your say at nationaltvawards.com
or by scanning this code on your screen
right now hold the phone up as though
you're taking a picture you'll get that
QR code and you can vote there
Piers would love it you know he would
love another gong for his dressing room
I can confirm that much and he is having
a lovely time of holiday he'll be back
soon now though plenty to debate on the
show the renewal of a debate in fact
it's almost as old as the artifacts it's
about should Britain return The Spoils
of Empire to the countries they were
originally taken from the British museum
has revealed close to 2 000 historic
pieces worth millions were stolen by one
of its senior curators and now Greece is
using this opportunity to demand the
return of the Elgin marbles held by the
museum in London
they claim thefts have shattered the
myth that it's the best and safest place
the UK to hold these types of artifacts
joining me to discuss all of this the
co-chair of the pan-african reparations
Council
former ukip MEP Roger Helmer and former
labor advisor to Jeremy corbyn James
Schneider thank you gentlemen making
time this evening let's get stuck right
in coffee
why is it necessary in your mind that
these types of artifacts should be
returned
well this should be written because they
belong to the people from whom they've
been stolen they've been literally
brought here through criminal you know
acts of armed robbery you know and it is
about time if people are waking up to
these crimes to atone for them and to
meet the demands for Preparatory Justice
that Africans and other colonized
peoples are actually
um
highlighting at this time then it is
about time that we actually talked about
what to do with them and it is you know
engaging with the communities that have
an interest in this matter who must be
seen as co-custodians these are world
heritage you know Treasures right now
and it is for
um us to deal with them as matters of
Preparatory Justice in which case for us
as in the international social movement
for African reparations what we are
calling for of which Paco is part what
we are calling for is let's have an old
party you know commission for truth and
respiratory Justice we call the
architage let's bring everybody around
the table let's discuss how we handle
this world heritage treasure so it is we
are not part of those who say retain
them return them to whom how to where if
in the British museum they can be stolen
then you know if you take it to these
corrupt governments and so-called
misleaders we have in places like Africa
today you know you can be sure that
they'll disappear right back so what we
are saying is that let's call everybody
around the table and ask custodians of
well Heritage Treasures let's see what
better let's get our facts right you say
it's armed robbery certainly in the case
of the Benin bronzes what was done was
legal in terms of international law at
that time uh in the case of the Elgin
marbles they were sold or given to Lord
Elgin so let's finish with this uh armed
robbery international law are you
talking about national law is it stood
at the time
and criminalities were conducted yeah
this this white supremacy racist attempt
to think that you know anything talk you
know conceived in Europe can be imposed
upon the world that happens
I am very tired
James please uh because obviously it's a
passion debate a lot of people do agree
that these artifacts were originally
stolen it's the repatriation process or
the returning it should be a
collaborative you know or should we be
keeping them here I think what Kofi said
is basically correct that there should
be a collaborative process to take the
ones back to the places that they were
taken from and we all think that theft
is wrong we think that this curator
who's allegedly Taken 2 000 pieces we
think that's wrong so we should think
it's wrong that they were taken in the
in the first place and there might be
some uh artifacts that are best place in
The Bridges Museum because for the
reasons Kofi was saying they can't go
back to to where they are or they'll be
seen by more people but when those ones
are displayed they should have the
history of how they were taken and how
they ended up there as part of the
permanent exhibition so that the museum
is not just a museum of some objects but
it's also a Museum of History and how
those objects have come to be in front
of the people the logic of this position
is that if we are saying that all
foreign artifacts must be returned you
will end up where an English Museum only
has English artifacts where a Nigerian
Museum only has Nigerian artifacts an
American Museum only has American
artifacts anybody who wishes to study
the history of human culture over a long
period would have to make a world tour
in order to see all these exhibits the
great thing about the British museum is
you get the whole thing together and you
can study the whole thing in one place
and the same applies to other major
museums in Europe and in America okay
who says Britain has a right to you know
hold on to stolen goods particularly
those brought here through criminal acts
of you know crimes against humanity like
War enslavement you know Invasion and so
on and so Britain has no such right
these are World Treasures you know these
are this belongs to all of humanity and
but we need to bring everybody around
the table so that they are no longer
that's all of humanity then why are we
returning them to it not because Britain
has no right to have taken them from
there in the first place through just
crimes of Against Humanity many people
lost their lives through the other way
around and the kingdom of Ashanti had
colonized Britain and had taken back for
example Stonehenge and that was
displayed in Kumasi you would be sitting
here saying no we should have those back
there that's part of our heritage that's
part of our culture and that would be a
perfectly reasonable thing now then what
should the museum director in Kumasi say
they should say well how are they going
to be displayed how can we work with you
to display them in the way that's going
to most show to the most people what
they are and that pays respect to the
culture from which they came from it in
the case of Stonehenge comes from the
you know Southwest of England 2 000
years ago the Romans colonized Britain I
don't know what they took but I dare so
they took a fair bit of stuff so far as
I know nobody is demanding the return of
any such materials so how far back are
you going to go in history well but we
would know if they were things that we
really were
be aware if Italy was holding
on years ago we were probably
the idea is that you know crime in the
past particularly crimes of armed
robbery you know through genocide and
echocyte upon you know millions of
people right that cannot be justified
under any circumstances
where it was not a crime of armed
robbery well that's your opinion
of the Ottomans who were occupying at
the time so it's a deal between
essentially a colonial power a wannabe
colonial power and an occupying power
in terms of in terms of Lord Elgin it
was done in the legitimate way what had
happened to them beforehand was not his
concern what do you think what do you
feel about the idea of having replicas
your point about you know if you return
everything to its Home Country you'll
never be able to observe things from
other countries I think that's a that's
a reasonable line of argument what about
the idea of replicating I I drove here
from the station I was driven in a taxi
we'd be passed Madam two swords now
Madame Tussauds is interesting and
people go and see it but what people
really want to see is the original I can
buy a copy of the Mona Lisa and I can
frame it up nicely and hang it in my
home and say there is the Mona Lisa but
actually nobody will be excited to come
and see my copy they're interested to go
and see the original that the original
artist worked on and I think that is a
fundamental difference
right to see the original you know
Europeans in here on the basis of crimes
against humanity that have impact up to
today in terms of devaluing human life
and also dehumanizing Europeans well
right this this whole white supremacy
racist arrogance
a few moments ago that's your opinion uh
but it is not an opinion which I share
uh and this is an opinion millions of
people the majority of humanity who's
been subjected to these crimes against
humanity all these views and so the
point is this we either do it in a
civilized way where we all come around
the table and look at this you know well
Heritage Treasures of humanity and pull
resources together in terms of where
they can best replace you know for
everybody to have you know the benefit
of learning from them in order to to to
to to to reorder our presence
you cannot keep holding on to them you
know with imperialist arrogance
I'm finished and our people are
do you think we're able to do this
civilly and we should be able to the
British museum has a huge opportunity to
do some leadership on this it should it
should do an audit of what it has it
should publish that it should reach out
to uh to everyone who Who's involved and
it should put in its permanent
collection how it got everything so that
we know when we go and we can see what
the objects are and how they got there
gentlemen what a debate I found that
fascinating thank you so much for coming
in uncensored next tonight the only fans
model causing outrage for advertising
her explicit content on billboards
across London and New York including
next to schools is outraged Justified
we'll debate that next
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
this is talk TV
welcome back now it is August and some
people are very upset about Billboards
apparently is something that happens in
August only fans model Eliza Rose Watson
paid for these giant posters advertising
her x-rated subscription content for
several sites across London and New York
they've sparked a flurry of complaints
to the UK's advertising Watchdog which
today ruled these Billboards were not
quote overtly sexual and therefore quite
all right to have up but Furious
campaigners want them banned arguing
that they are normalizing obscenity so
do they have a point more on this I'm
joined by the only fans model at the
center of the route Eliza Rose Watson
and the political commentator Lauren
Chen ladies thank you very much for
joining us
um Eliza first of all you must be
relieved obviously that the Billboards
are staying up
um and
what do you make of the arguments that
this is inappropriate and obscene
well firstly you know I am encouraged
and um pleased that the ASA have ruled
what they've ruled
um I think in general what I make of the
argument is you know it's understandable
in a sense that if someone doing
something new there's a lot of
misconception about what only fans is
and what only fans isn't but
only fans is now a household name it's
no good denying it or pushing it under
the carpet that's what's gonna do damage
you know we need to face it we need to
talk about it we need to
not really focus as much on whether it's
right or wrong whether people should be
doing it or shouldn't be doing it the
fact is they are doing it it's here to
stay we should be focusing on
how we approach it is turning a blind
eye onto it realistic let alone helpful
is Banning it and shaming it just an old
outdated archaic approach which has
never really worked for any societal
issue I think that's
okay interesting the argument does come
up a lot about
um sex work and I only find it's
somewhat in the room of that uh anyone
who's not aware I feel like everyone in
the world is aware of what only fans is
but it's when people pay uh content
creators for pretty sexy pictures sexual
pictures and they can be to the very
pornographic end or to the lighter end
as well we've just shown you some
pictures there that were softened for
our evening audience Lauren Chen uh
joins us now as well Lauren um
do you buy that argument that we should
be more accepting of this type of work
in society otherwise if we clamp down on
it then it will be worse for a lot of
women
well I think there are plenty accepted
already as a society people are
perfectly able to start only fans
accounts and not only that but become
very financially successful for a slim
minority I think that includes Eliza the
question we were talking about here is
is it appropriate is it okay to
advertise pornography in places where
children can see it you mentioned that
some of these Billboards are right next
to a school and in my opinion the answer
is clearly no and I have to say Eliza
regardless of what the overall Watchdog
ruling is that doesn't mean that you as
a business owner as the person who is
sponsoring these Billboards needs to
keep them up especially the ones that I
think are are under the most controversy
which are the ones near the school you
are able to take them down there are
other ways you can advertise for your
only fans account including I would say
appearing on this show that don't expose
children to this to the concept of
pornography uh you know young girls the
idea of selling their bodies young boys
the idea that women are Commodities
there are other ways to go about this
even if you insist on having an only
fans account that would draw a lot less
fire from parents especially let's give
Eliza a chance to respond to that but
also according to the information I've
got the Billboards uh one of which is
located around 450 meters from a school
which is a fair distance the advertising
standards agency did come back and said
look these Billboards are all around New
York and London children walk around
those cities all the time they're going
to see them anyway whether or not the
ruling is correct or not I people have
different opinions on that but Eliza I
mean your chance to respond there are
you advertising pornography widely is it
necessary to do that that's what
Lauren's saying
I think my intention behind the ads was
to do exactly this to start a discussion
that's what my intention was and I think
that's been achieved I will point out
I'm not the first person to put an only
fans logo on an advert there are boxes
and formula one drivers that have the
only fans logo in exactly the same way
on their helmets on their shorts on
their clothing
I think the issue here is people are
putting two and two together with a
woman in the logo I will also say the
only over reference to pornography on my
ad was the graffiti on it and this is
what sparked the Press I got and
ultimately
all the attention this has received the
ad was very clearly designed for adults
I'm a 34 year old woman
all my social media audience is between
the ages of 25 and 35 and 98.8 male
um I will also point out that in the
same vicinity there were alcohol ads on
bus stops presumably where these
children would sit and wait for a bus
home from school the only difference is
that conversations have been had around
alcohol that's the difference and this
is what I'm starting to do here the
other thing is just because there's an
ad with a bottle of beer on it it
doesn't mean a child or a minor could
walk straight into an off license and
buy a beer they'd have to provide ID and
what people don't understand about
owning plans is
same applies there it's actually even
harder even as a Creator when I buy a
new mobile phone I have to physically
call up my network provider provide ID
on credit card in order to even access
the platform and that's even without
subscribing ask I think those are all
really good points to raise you know the
alcohol one as well that Lauren's point
about um
the money aspect of this and the
attention you've received you said your
intention behind it was to raise this
debate of course that has created more
marketing for you and you're going to
receive likely more customers and more
money from this
um was that part of it as well
not really I didn't expect any real
increase in revenue from the Billboards
um as you might know we already
advertise we advertise online
um
I think as well like the point around it
was again to just raise a discussion and
I'd also like to add at this point
the ads do not glorify or glamorize the
use of only fans in any way and I will
make this point about the money
the money can be really good for a small
minority as was mentioned however there
are great sacrifices to be made for
people who do only fans you post a sexy
picture on even Instagram it's there for
your whole life and it's a short-lived
it's a very short-lived career so
these are the kind of things that I
think we need to be talking about Lauren
and it sorry Eliza we're just running
short of time I just want to ask Lauren
final words uh whether you're convinced
by any of this
well I think it's somewhat silly to say
that the Billboards weren't done at
least in part for increased Revenue
that's the point of billboards and
advertising and I appreciate that Eliza
does bring out of the fact that there
are downsides to only fans but the thing
is that's not what's mentioned on the
spill board on this billboard they're
Simply Her provocative pose a link to
her social media and only fans accounts
and obviously uh children should have
their social media usage monitored by
parents but at the same time I don't
think it's too much to ask for people
who make pornography like Eliza to not
directly Market to Children which is in
part what she's doing there are other
ways she could advertise where you
wouldn't have this fur where they
wouldn't uh be exposed to children but
she is I think specifically trying to
normalize and mainstream she even said
only fans which is not a good thing this
is not a positive for Society for men or
for women
that's interesting oh go on quickly
Eliza because statistically
teenagers are way more likely to be
exposed to sexual imagery on places like
Facebook than they are only fans I
obviously would never purposely have put
this ad next to a school however I think
it's actually you can't take it down you
could take it down at any point you're
the one paying for it it doesn't it
doesn't need to be there regardless of
what the agency says you have the
ability to take it down
I did six days after the complaints it
came down so so you agree with that I
guess the complaints in that case
not particularly no I I agree with the
fact I would not like to be directly
directly marketing at children however
it's naive what I was going to say is
it's naive to assume that a teenager
with a mobile phone would not have seen
imagery like this before and this I find
con concerning the fact that people
don't know that or just don't want to
accept it the point of the ads and I
think they've achieved the point is to
start this discussion and maybe raise
we are fresh at our time we have had
that discussion we appreciate both your
points of view
on censored next tonight the Spanish
football Scandal gripping the world
Spain's fa Chief is accused of sexual
assault for kissing World Cup winning
player Jenny hermaso on the lips he said
sorry but is it enough we'll debate
[Music]
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King Q I
think it's only one for one king
he's mocked your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail stop working just cause
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
war but he's making me cry again they're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Hugh Edwards has been revealed as the
presenter at the center of the BBC
Scandal he is the most important
television presenter on the BBC that we
pay for whatever torture he may have
been going through in that in some way
is an excuse yeah for what appears to be
an abuse of power when they first got
together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth because you're
not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job that resonates with
people Elaine Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I
obviously wish I'd never met him
the conservative party can certainly win
the next election yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
let it roll
[Music]
stop producing oil the knock-on effect
is far larger than just CO2 I nearly
have empathy when I'm speaking to them I
know you're probably going to vote me
after church
some of them they're easily lit
you can kiss my American ass thank you
very much very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you there's a
threat that you'd be worried about so
are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
what does a woman make
you weren't asked to give evidence to
the grand jury I'm the only one that has
Battalion materials you don't drink
never taken drugs you're stinking rich
should be concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
coming up on the talk Britain's High
streets suffer a violent shoplifting
epidemic fueled by Soaring inflation and
rotting food bills and that West Sparks
Fury after handing its disgraced former
boss 2.4 million quid a month after
resigning in a row over Nigel farage's
bank account and controversial giant
Billboards advertising raunchy website
only fans set finger swagging and pulses
racing that's all coming up at nine
welcome back nowadays the smooching
Scandal that is overshadowing Spain's
World Cup win Spain's fa Chief Luis
rubial is kissed one of their World Cup
winners fully on the mouth at the end of
the match without consent and with
millions of people watching around the
world he has apologized but Spain's
prime minister Pedro Sanchez says it's
not good enough for the latest on this
I'm joined by Spanish football
journalist semra Hunter semra thanks for
making time
um just reminds our viewers about this
and why it's got people so outraged
well one of the main reasons why it has
people so outraged is that there was a
new law put into place last year which
is called only yes is yes and it's about
consent so in the absence of consent in
an action like this it's considered to
be sexual aggression so in other words
it's considered to be a crime actually
so it has people very outraged because
this is a boss kissing a subordinate in
this case an employee not just privately
but publicly in front of the entire
world in the Pinnacle of her career in a
crowning moment and it's forever going
to be tainted and so many people feel as
though he has crossed the line he's the
president of the Federation this never
should have happened it's completely
unacceptable behavior and actually in
the protocols themselves of the
Federation it also borrows from this law
and it very clearly states that if you
kiss someone by force it is completely
unacceptable behavior and there should
be immediate actions taking place
unfortunately the immediate actions have
been to try and cover this up to try and
protect the president and to try and
keep him in the job which is then caused
even more outrage over the last few days
so it's fascinating uh background that I
wasn't aware of about that in Spain and
the rules I've got um two of the regular
panelists in the studio joining me this
evening Esther Krakow talk to the
contributor and socialist and author
Grace Blakely they've been listening and
we want to bring them into the
conversation to get their reaction to
this uh not simplified by just saying
there's four women in a conversation
about this but it is about a man kissing
a woman without consent Esther uh
listening to that what were your
thoughts I mean I think it's important
whenever we talk about these sort of
conversations around what we consider
sexual harassment not to patronize women
uh and the reason why I'm saying this is
because the lady in question came out
she's 33 years old she's not a child she
came out and said you know we have a
close relationship obviously I made the
point that culturally you know the
Spanish the Spaniards and the French are
more like Huggy and physically kissy
kissy and all of that I'm not saying
it's okay because I wouldn't appreciate
it how however if the person in question
said actually it's fine we have a close
relationship I wasn't offended and he
did come out and apologize as well if
she was offended why are we making a
fuss about it who are we to tell her how
she should feel about it Samra
thank you very much there's actually two
things I want to say to that one
the apology was Half Baked if you
actually listen to the actual language
he uses the word seguramente that
actually means probably so he said
probably I made a mistake he actually
absorbed himself of any kind of blame on
top of that he made it sound like it was
mutual and it very much was not mutual
that's why so many people were so upset
with this apology because it came across
as though it was forced because he knew
he was under threat of losing his job
and that's why the president of Spain
also said this isn't good enough the
second thing is about those statements
you were referring to just now it has
since come to light and this is
absolutely atrocious by the way if it
turns out to be true it has since come
to light that Jenny never made those
statements the Communications Department
within the Spanish Federation made it up
she never said it but the thing is
here's the issue's issue I have with
that everyone saw it right this is on
National Television so I mean you know
if you want really wants a sexual
assault I don't think live TV at a World
Cup final would be a good place to start
and also in the I feel it feels like
we're getting upset on behalf of someone
I this is what female empowerment looks
like I want her to open her mouth get on
TV and say how she feels about if she's
really upset about it
the thing is the issue quickly because
she actually did speak on Instagram
there's a public video you can see her
where she was asked by one of her
teammates
how she felt about it and she said she
didn't like it and then she also said
what am I supposed to do so that is the
oh yeah that's the point isn't it
because we know already how much
pressure these um football players are
under as women there's literally every
time they play a football game we have
this massive debate about women in
football most of them don't want to be
defined by the fact that they're a woman
they just want to play football right
well then so whenever stuff like this
comes up they must feel under immense
pressure to kind of sweep it under the
rug to say oh it's fine there's nothing
wrong with this you know just to
basically get back to doing it even when
they aren't made to be honorable because
realistically he's not going to have
done that to a man I was just about to
make it
because the men smack each other's
bottoms and do all sorts of things like
this is that appropriate also the the
the coach for the english team is a
woman if she kissed the the teammates if
we'd want would we make a big fuss out
of this as well and it's an interesting
counteractual I'm not sure I feel like
it would still be weird
it's her he did didn't just kiss her and
also we have we have to include the
cultural norms here because I understand
why this would make news in the UK
because we're a lot more prudish and
conservative in the way that we show
affection
because yes we are more affectionate we
are more physically we are warm however
yes we do tend to give each other hugs
we do tend to give each other two kisses
on the cheeks but it never crosses a
line and kissing someone on the lips and
the way that he did did cross the line
and therefore a lot of people here in
Spain are completely against his actions
they feel as though it was completely
inappropriate and they are no way to
defend it obviously there is a
subsection within society that does so
because there's a very big problem with
sexism in machismo that still runs
rampant in this country that we still
need to work on and that's part of the
issue here as well the Reales even said
he wasn't entirely sure what he did
wrong or that he even did anything wrong
and that speaks volumes in and of itself
that's a red flag that there's still a
very big problem here to be addressed
and actually many members of the media
who initially defended him have actually
since in the few past days they've
switched sides and they've actually
heard arguments from women they've heard
arguments from their people and they
said actually you know what we were
wrong about this we apologize and
actually what rebellious did was wrong
and it's not just the kiss in and of
itself it's the tip of the iceberg
there's so many other things that have
happened
in the past and recently if you look at
his celebrations on the pitch the way
that he was hugging the players who was
kissing them on their cheeks also I
don't know if you saw it when he was in
the stands standing next to the queen of
Spain her daughter Jenny Infantino some
of the high-ranking officials of of the
British government as well that were
there he grabbed his genitals in
celebrating Spain's win what kind of
behavior
everything though him grabbing excuse me
him grabbing his balls is not assaulting
anyone with all due respect I don't want
to see it but he's not salty
with all due respect if I understand
what you're saying trust me I know
nobody will do that to you or the people
that have complained about this being
inappropriate fine but I just don't want
us to get upset on someone else's behalf
when there's a 33 year old we're not
doing that you're a grown woman who can
speak for herself and she has spoken for
herself the statement that I read and if
she wants to dispute that that's
absolutely fine
was not actually written by we are out
of time
you've been great it's great to get your
perspective thank you to all three of
you that is it from us tonight keeper
uncensored whatever you're doing good
night
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]